.
>> Sean: TONIGHT ALL EYESOR
UKRAINE.
A BLOODY NEW CHAPTER OF WAR IS
UNFOLDING BEFORE OUR VERY EYES.
CIVILIANS ARE IN RUSSIA'S CROSS
HARRIS.
I HAVE BEEN CRITICAL OF
UKRAINE'S GOVERNMENT AND
CORRUPTION IN THE COUNTRY.
AND BY GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS.
NOW PRESIDENT ZELENSKY AND
ORDINARY UKRAINIANS ARE FIGHTING
AGAINST AN INVASION.
INNOCENT MEN, WOMEN AND CHILDREN
ARE DYING AT THE HANDS OF A TINE
TYRANT NAMED VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THIS SIX-YEAR-OLD WAS KILLED IN
SOUTHERN UKRAINE.
SHE WAS PALE.
HER BROWN HAIR WAS PULLED BACK
WITH A RUBBER BAND.
HER BLOODY PAJAMA PANTS WERE
DECORATED WITH CARTOON UNICORNS
AND HER BLOOD IS ON VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S HANDS.
MY QUESTION TO THE SOLDIERS
WAGING THIS WAR ON CIVILIAN AND
CHILDREN, REALLY?
IS THIS THE LEGACY YOU WANT FOR
YOUR LIFE.
DO YOU HAVE THE COURAGE TO STAND
UP.
THIS IS A HARD TAPE TO WATCHER
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO SEE.
TAKE A LOOK. BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO SEE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> [SHOUTING].
>> [CRYING].
>> Sean: THE MEDICAL PERSONNEL
TRY TO RESUSCITATE THIS GIRL,
THEY ARE CRYING.
VLADIMIR PUTIN KILLED THAT
SIX-YEAR-OLD GIRL AND STARTED
THIS WAR.
VLADIMIR PUTIN KILLS EVEN
CHILDREN TO SATISFY HIS
AMBITIONS.
YOU MAY NOTICE HERE, BELOW THE
U.S. FLAG IS THE UKRAINIAN FLAG
FOR PEOPLE LIKE THAT LITTLE GIRL
STANDING IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
INNOCENT PEOPLE OF UKRAINE.
THE WORLD NEEDS A NEW RULE.
I WANT THIS NEW RULE.
IF YOU ARE A MURDERING TYRANT
WHO INVADES A SOVEREIGN COUNTRY
AND KILL INNOCENT MEN, WOMEN AND
CHILDREN YOU FORFEIT YOUR RIGHT
TO RUN ANY COUNTRY.
THE RUSSIAN MILITARY NEEDS TO
STOP TAKING ORDERS FROM THIS
MURDERER.
PUTIN SHOULD NOT BE RUNNING
RUSSIAN.
HE IS A THUG KILLING INNOCENT
CIVILIANS AND CIVILIZED
COUNTRIES MUST REMOVE HIM BY ANY
MEANS NECESSARY.
SEENS LIKE THIS ARE EVERYWHERE
AS RUSSIA BOMBS SCHOOLS AND
HOSPITALS.
THESE ARE NOT TARGETED ATTACKS
AGAINST UKRAINIAN MILITARY
INSTALLATIONS.
IT'S VLADIMIR PUTIN ATTEMPTING
TO PUNISH UKRAINIANS THROUGH
VIOLENCE.
UKRAINE'S MINISTER OF HEALTH
OVER 350 CIVILIANS HAVE BEEN
KILLED.
IT'S LIKELY MUCH HIGHER
INCLUDING MANY CHILDREN OVER THE
WEEKEND.
HERE'S WHAT FORMER DONALD TRUMP
SAID AT CPAC ABOUT PUTIN'S
HOSTILE INVASION.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE A WEAK
PRESIDENT NOT REPORTED BY OTHER
NATIONS, YOU HAVE A CHAOTIC
WORLD.
I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT PRESIDENT
PUTIN MADE HIS DECISION TO
ATTACK UKRAINE ONLY AFTER
WATCHING THE PATHIETIC
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN.
THE PROBLEM IS NOT THAT PUTIN IS
SMART, OF COURSE HE IS SMART,
THE REAL PROBLEM IS THAT OUR
LEADERS ARE DUMB.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> DUMB.
THEY HAVE ALLOWED HIM TO GET
AWAY WITH THIS TRAVESTY AND
ASSAULT ON HUMANITY.
IT'S SO SAD.
PUTIN IS PLAYING BIDEN LIKE
A DRUM.
>> Sean: WE PLAYED THE TAPE OF
DONALD TRUMP WITHOUT A SINGLE NO
LECTUREING IN THE FACE OF THE
LEADER OF NATO.
WE AMERICA PAYING THE BULK OF
MONEY FOR NATO TO PROTECT
WESTERN EUROPEAN COUNTRIES FROM
BEING ATTACKED BY PUTIN AND YET
THEY ARE MAKING BILLION DOLLARS
DEALS AND BECOMING MORE RELIANT
ON VLADIMIR PUTIN AND RUSSIA FOR
ENERGY NEEDS AND HOW STUPID THAT
WHOLE POLICY IS.
I WOULD PLAY WHAT THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN SAID BUT HE
WAS NOWHERE TO BE FOUND THIS
WEEKEND.
WHILE PUTIN WAS PUTTING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS IN PLAY, JOEY TOOK TIME
OFF IN DELAWARE.
DOING WHAT?
I DON'T KNOW.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS RIGHT.
THE WESTERN WORLD IS BEING
STUPID.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THIS THUG
FOR WHO HE IS.
AND WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THE ONLY THING THAT WORKS IS
STRENGTH.
ACCORDING TO A HARVARD AND
HARRIS POLL TWO-THIRDS OF
AMERICANS BELIEVE THIS IS ATTACK
WOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED UNDER
DONALD TRUMP?
WHY?
BECAUSE PUTIN FEARED DONALD
TRUMP.
PUTIN KNEW IN TRUMP SAID IT, HE
WOULD DO.
WEAKNESS INVITES CHAOS AND
CARNAGE.
DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T NEED, AFTER
4 YEARS OF HIS PRESIDENCY, HE
MADE AMERICA ENERGY INDEPENDENT
AND AN EXPORTER OF ENERGY.
THAT'S A BIG FACTOR IN ALL OF
THIS.
WITHOUT A DOUBT BIDEN'S
DISASTROUS WITHDRAW FROM
AFGHANISTAN EMBOLDENED EVERY
DICTATOR AROUND THE WORLD.
I SAID IT WOULD.
I WISH I WAS WRONG.
DAY 198.
WEDNESDAY 2 MONDAY DAYS.
JOE BIDEN TURNED THE PAGE.
NEVER MENTIONED THEM.
THE MEDIA MOB NEVER MENTIONS
AMERICANS LEFT BEHIND WANT GREEN
CARD HOLDERS LEFT BEHIND.
OUR AFGHAN ALLIES ABANDONED AND
STABBED IN THE BACK.
ABANDONED ALL BY JOE BIDEN.
IF JOE BIDEN WERE A DESCENT
LEADER HE WOULD ADDRESS THIS IN
TOMORROW'S STATE OF THE UNION.
HE WOULD ANNOUNCE A NEW WAVE OF
SANCTIONS AGAINST PUTIN'S OIL
AND EXPAND ENERGY PRODUCTION TO
MEET THE ENERGY NEEDS OF OUR
COUNTRY AND OUR ALLIES IN
EUROPE.
JOE'S ECONOMIC ENERGY POLICIES
HAVE HURT EVERY AMERICAN FAMILY.
WE PAY MORE FOR EVERY ITEM WE
BUY.
EVERYTHING COSTS HEAR TO GET IT
TO THE STORE AND FOR A GALLON OF
GASOLINE.
HE GAVE UP AMERICA'S ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE AND COMPROMISED OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
HE COMPROMISED THE WORLD
SECURITY.
WHO WOULD THINK AFTER INHERITING
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE JOE BIDEN
IMPORTS 232 MILLION BARRELS OF
OIL FROM RUSSIA AND A BILLION OF
BARRELS OF OIL FROM IRAN FOR THE
FIRST TIME SINCE 1991.
JOE BIDEN IS BEHOLDENED TO THE
RADICA
RADICAL NEW GREEN DEAL
SOCIALISTS AND HE WON'T ADMIT HE
IS WRONG.
ITALY IS CONSIDERING REVIVING
THE COUNTRY'S COAL PLANTS TO
BREAK THEIR ENERGY DEPENDENCY ON
RUSSIA.
JOE SHOULD BLOCK THE U.S. FROM
IMPORTING ALL RUSSIAN OIL AND
EVERY DESCENT COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD SHOULD PUT THAT MAIN
SANCTION ON VLADIMIR PUTIN IN
RUSSIA.
THAT WOULD MEAN THE MOST TO
PUTIN.
THAT'S THE ONE SANCTION THEY
HAVE NOT PUT IN PLACE.
ANY SANCTION THAT DOESN'T HIT
RUSSIA'S ENERGY SECTOR IS
POINTLESS.
RUSSIA IS A GAS STATION
MASQUERADINGS A COUNTRY.
BUT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
KILLED THE KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE.
THIS SOUTH OF THEIR CONTROL.
REALLY?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHY IS THE U.S. BUYING
RUSSIAN GAS?
CAN WE PLEDGE NOT TO BUY ANYMORE
>> I THINK THERE IS CONFUSION.
ONE MOMENT.
[SILENCE].
HMMM.
AS IT RELATES TO RUSSIAN GAS,
THE UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T DICTATE WHERE THE U.S.
MARKET SILENCE OUR PRODUCTS OR
REQUIRES PRODUCTION FOR DOMESTIC
CONSUMPTION.
>> Sean: THE NEW GREEN DEAL
PEOPLE FOR CHARGE AND TAKE TOP
PRIORITY OVER THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND OVER THE WORLD PEACE
WE WOULD HAVE BEING ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
UNDER THEIR LEADERSHIP THE WORLD
IS FALLING APART.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN: SINCE JOE
BIDEN'S WAS INAUGURATED.
AD THE BORDER CRISIS AND THE
CRISIS IN AFGHANISTAN AND
A FULL-BLOWN WAR IN EUROPE
BREAKING OUT BEFORE OUR EYES.
THE STATE OF THE UNION -- WELL
THE STATE OF THE WORLD IS NOT IN
A GREAT PLACE BECAUSE AMERICA
DOESN'T HAVE A STRONG LEADER.
JOE BIDEN IS PROBABLY ASLEEP AND
PROBABLY DOESN'T KNOW WHAT DAY
IT IS.
TOMORROW WE ARE TO EXPECT JOE
BIDEN TO DOUBLE DOWN ON THE NEW
GREEN DEAL SOCIAL PLATFORM AS
A CURE ALL FOR AMERICA'S WOES.
THAT'S THE DUMBEST POLICY YOU
COULD EMBRACE.
EVEN ABC AND "WASHINGTON POST"
POLL HAS HIM AT AN ALL TIME LOW
AT